[Music]
good morning my hair looks dumb we're
vlogging welcome to the first ever try
guys vlog so apparently the try guy is
supposed to start vlogging now telling
this is a stupid idea I'm
having burgers for breakfast what's
going on today well first of all let's
give these hot shades on yeah we're
gonna be trying this basically we're
gonna do big video one week vlog the
next week we thought you know we could
probably let you guys in our real lives
you guys let us know if you like it
we'll keep doing it if you don't like it
then I don't know man named Zane I'm
gonna bleed you don't know where the
flag is you don't know who DeParle bred
to do you don't know there's another pub
brother fuzzy it's no one and nobody's
here that's Ned that's Eugene that sack
Hey look
cutes here Wow good job Keith you're so
cute what are you saying man
I had three burgers for a toast flappers
because if you ever had hamburgers for
breakfast
No I'm late for my dance appointment and
ready to go film myself in
public like a crazy person so I
guess today we got to find something
cool to do
hey guys I got something to show you hey
guys so he puts the teacup on his dick
[Music]
there we go here we go
is he serving somebody T we have more
pubes than this guy yeah everybody hey
you don't have four that's a foamer
right over there let's be adults about
this please somebody put a teacup on my
dick that's the good stuff
let's go far no more yeah great three
two one that's amazing yeah it's cold
that's great okay now now you need to be
able to pull it off your stuff okay well
I'm gonna come over here I won't okay
[Music]
not only do you see it go horribly wrong
but then you see his dick oh my god on
the full mangina this is when the game's
not here you know what hell looks like
being at the dentist surrounded by
pictures of your own teeth you look like
a 12th century Jesus you do only maybe
like crouch down next to me yourself
though yeah I'll sit I'll sit with you 3
2 1 it's very little oh my but you did
up on my dick and you're a little
crybaby about a little spill so I did it
yeah you did it yeah so is it time to
ramp it up ramp it it's grossly what I
think okay oh you look great
very like a high-fashion photo shoot in
a way you know your tees that popping
off just the way you like it
piping hot yeah
three two one go well it didn't work
let's get some of these shards away from
Ned's naked body why don't we try to
imitate Alice it's certainly both okay
well I guess we're a pretty cool dad
yeah nailed it nailed it I thought we
were gonna do it slower No
did you do anything differently that
time did I do any different like to this
I hate no I certainly did it really fast
again Eugene has great beautiful
exciting team he man insect you got a
little gross oh yeah no it's a thumb is
that nose and the forehead so we are
ready for the new approach we have the
track on its highest Ned what's that tea
bottle for just so I can really smack it
and not hurt my hands see you but then
the tea's gonna get is it'll work trust
me okay
my god what the no what are you
guys doing
I thought we were blogging today why
that video I texted do it just it's cool
to take your pants off but tea cup with
water in it
so this is that first line and hope you
liked it why we'll see you next time
Triceratops
I am the best goddamn dancer at the
American Ballet Academy and the are
you
no one all right let's do this I'm
wearing a play come on baby
[Music]
all you needed was an Asian we're trying
to do another try guys shoot you like
this maybe we'll do some more goofy
it wasn't as bad as I thought it in the
car rolling out his window